is Blake Shelton ready for kids of his
own plus we're with all three of the new
American Idol judges displayed Shelton
have a new Muse who has not Gwen Stefani
the country star rode shotgun with
Chelsea Handler for a carpool karaoke
the series last night now I'll save you
from Chelsea's horrific singing but
watch what happens when Blake tries to
write a country song about her life step
1 identify a love interest I don't have
a love interest so let's make one up
well of course somebody's interested in
you I don't know you know it's just
there's everyone I guess I have to wait
for somebody to get divorced or
something that's a country song out
there I don't like kids what about that
this might be a problem for a country
song as everybody likes kids everybody
likes kids no no yeah I could be the one
country girl that doesn't have them
speaking of kids Blake and Gwen have
been together for nearly two years she
of course has three boys of her own but
could the couple have any children of
their own in the future well guess who
tried to get that answer from Blake
himself our snow fish Lacey guilty guy
yeah I have to I mean I recently flew to
Blake's home state of Oklahoma where he
was throwing a concert to celebrate his
new restaurant and bar opening it was
called old red Tishomingo that is his
baby right now but look with all the
time he's been spending with Gwen and
the kids in Oklahoma I had to ask if he
wants one of his own one day you see
yourself having more kids I mean the
kids clearly adore you you're putting
them in music videos that sparked like a
paternal instinct in you I don't know I
think the voice sparked that in me if
anything it was early on and I've just
kind of rolled with it so good I tried
you know what can you do Blake did tell
me he's always had this protective side
to him ever since he started on the
voice it just kind of erupted been
touring these kids really sparks that
and you can totally tell in fact last by
a contestant Sophia Bowman even said she
always thought he would make a cool dad
look that's Adam he loved that comment
but it's true don't you think you'd make
a cool dad
absolutely make a cool dad I think
Blake's just a cool guy in general and
of course leave it to Adam to make fun
of him for that when Adam he's a dad
he's got another one on the way yeah all
of it
you guys could catch more of Sophie sit
down with Blake about his new album
Texoma Shore on her series certified
country not episode drops on Friday guys
thank you so much appreciate yeah all
right well Blake's buddy Luke Bryan has
taken a page out of the country singers
book because while Blake joked that he
had a big hand and Luke joining American
Idol as a judge I will 2.0 is officially
underway just 17 months after the
original was done so and yesterday was
their first day of auditions
Luke has joined Katy Perry and Lionel
Richie behind the table what's gonna
make this show are these guys because
let me tell you the trio has already
started to bond but they won't be
relying on any of those mean-spirited
gimmicks of idols past which one of you
would you say is like the tough judge
sort of Simon esque is there one of you
that stands well wah lah no put it best
he you know we're all art we are all
artists okay we didn't we're not some
sit behind the desk record label god
that's um so wouldn't we but I mean
we're we're artists so we know what it's
like to be in that scenario where we're
laying our you're pouring our heart out
on the line and and you know we revert
back to how people handled us in our
path to get here and so I think we're
you know we ran long on our first day
because we were really really careful
now I know what you're thinking what
made American Idol so great when it
first premiered was the hilarious awful
auditions and of course Simon Cowell but
hey the voice can tug at our
heartstrings and make us laugh if the
new Idol can do the same I'll be happy
besides the real fireworks to watch out
for will be between these competing
shows especially between Blake and Luke
in one room
for old country boy on TV Blake and I'm
here for that
all right guys finally Sam Smith has
been a busy man fresh off the success of
his new single too good at goodbyes our
favorite soul singer just teased that
his next single everyone prays in the
end drops on October 10th oh and by the
way he's got a new man that's right the
person behind some of our favorite sad
love songs doesn't look so sad anymore
Sam was spotted sharing a smooch with
boyfriend Brandon Flynn in New York City
and if you could actually see Brandon
space in that photo you'd recognize him
as one of the stars of 13 reasons why
now it appears Sam's relationship status
has gone from zero to 60 because just
last month Sam said he was insanely
single during a beats 1 radio
interviewer well either way the more he
lives and loves the more music we get so
good on you Sammy boy and we're gonna
start you guys on a four on the John and
Chrissy scale we don't have much to go
off of yeah except for that photo and
Brandon you could get into a little bit
more Sam Smith is kissing yet are you
guys thanks for watching today if you
got a couple's name for Sam and Brandon
I want to hear it be sure to like
comment and share this video and I'll
see you guys tomorrow
I'm Way too good at goodbyes